- I'm the GM of Contact
Center for Zendesk.
It was interesting, Jay
Backstage was saying sort of,
"I know the brand Zendesk,
I think I used it in
college in a side job.
I didn't know that they did
anything in contact center,"
which is great, which is why I'm here,
and I'm delighted to tell you
about the business that I run.
It was a result of an
acquisition earlier in the year
of my company, which was Local Measure.
We've now built that platform
natively into Zendesk,
and that's what I'm gonna
talk a little bit about today.
But actually, I'm not gonna
talk about myself first.
We are gonna talk a little bit
about what we think the future
of contact center looks like.
I'm out with customers every day,
and we also spoke to
about a thousand customers
to synthesize some of their worries.
Some of them cried in the
corner when they spoke
to us about the future of contact center,
and we synthesize it down to five trends
and things that you might
want to think about.
This was a quote from one of our customers
who runs a healthcare business,
which I think summed up the Zendesk view
of where things are going,
digital agents, human agents,
and all of these channels
working seamlessly together
to deliver a great customer experience.
It sounds simple,
but I think probably like
all of you are feeling,
this technology change
is probably the fastest
that I've certainly
ever seen in my career.
I remember the dot-com boom,
I remember the social mobile trend
which was gonna take over the world,
and each of those technology trends
sort of impacted the way that we work.
The impact, I think, on service from AI
is possibly the fastest.
I'm fortunate to be in a
business within Zendesk
that we believe has the
biggest AI footprint
of any vendor globally
with 20,000 customers live in production
using our AI services.
Our CEO on Bloomberg yesterday
said that's a $200 million run rate.
So this isn't tech that's in the lab,
this isn't things that are
happening on POCs and trials.
This is in the real world,
impacting your customers, taking
cost out of your business.
I'm that excited.
I'm throwing the clicker around.
What some of these customers told us
is as service is getting
better, particularly on voice,
they're seeing more volume.
Nicholas and I have a bet,
who's in the audience,
I bet with him that in two years time,
20% of all of the service automation
that comes over voice,
all the service calls will be automated.
Our customers tell us 50%.
We are clearly not there yet on voice.
On digital channels, we have customers
seeing 50, 60, 70, 80% automation.
Voice has taken a little bit longer
because the quality
hasn't quite been there.
But it's really interesting
to see our customers
are telling us kind of they believe
over the next two to three years
50% will be fully automated,
and there's a mandate from the board
and there's pressure coming down to AI,
as one customer told me,
and I asked them, "What does AI mean?"
And they said, "Well, the
board told us to add AI."
So I think some of the metrics and the,
and the reasons are still
sort of being unpacked.
For us, it's all about
driving a resolution,
driving an outcome
for the customers that delivers value.
We're sort of maniacally
focused on resolution
as the unit of measurement
to make sure that,
you know, customers are
having their issues resolved
and we're actually even charging customers
for our own services based on resolution
because we believe that, like,
when you deliver an outcome
for a customer,
that delivers the most
value back to the business.
I think one thing that is abundantly clear
is sort of the old model
of running a contact center
is slowly dying,
and we have to reimagine
the ways of working,
we have to reimagine the way
we staff contact centers,
we have to reimagine
the ways that we show up
for customers and the channels.
One I think big inhibitor that we saw,
particularly for voice and voice AI,
was that customers felt
that the quality hasn't
historically been there
with chatbots and AI interactions.
I mean we've all had
experiences of talking to a bot
that hasn't understood us
and going around and
around in endless loops.
You know, one of my solutions consultants
said to me, and my Australian accent,
Australians use 30
different variants for yes,
and that's ya and yis,
and I think if you don't program that
in many of the bots the right way,
you sort of have a bot that
doesn't understand you,
and it becomes an incredibly
frustrating experience
with these deterministic bots.
What's really cool with
a new version of AI bots
is that they can understand
the kind of context
and route you the right way,
and therefore what
customers are telling us
is they're finally comfortable
with the level of quality on AI,
and we're seeing now
finally a mass adoption
in the contact center space.
So without further ado,
we tried to summarize
what was a thousand different perspectives
from contact center leaders.
I mean, you ask one contact center leader
for one opinion and they give you five.
We try to bring it together
into sort of five core themes,
which also align, I think, very nicely
to what Zendesk thinks is happening
in voice and around the contact center.
The first kind of conviction we have
is that all interactions
in the contact center
are gonna begin with AI.
The idea of routing,
the idea of IVRs is sort
of a legacy concept,
and essentially the AI
becomes the concierge
and the front door for your organization.
And so what that means is
then we need to sort of skill
our contact centers in a different way.
Those level 100, level 200 agents
become the AI,
and we shift the human agents
to level 300 and level 400,
the more complex tasks.
The challenge we have in assessing the ROI
is all of our metrics
are currently broken,
which we'll get to in a moment.
Our CTO joked yesterday,
"I mean, what is the use
of an average speed to
answer when, you know,
an AI can answer in 100
or 200 milliseconds?"
So we have to reimagine
what we're tracking
and why we're tracking.
But our house view
is that there'll be no
press one for sales,
press two for support,
or shouting agent into the phone.
Like, the AI will start,
will understand the context,
will self-serve and execute
procedures where it can,
and will route to the right
human at the right time.
The second prediction that we have,
just like that average speed
to answer concept goes away,
we think hold times vanish as well.
I was at a breakfast yesterday
where the person next to me said
they're actually calling
a lot more frequently
into their favorite brand
because the call gets picked up instantly.
And so I think we have
this perverse impact
where people don't pick up the
phone or don't call a brand
because they know the
experience is so shitty,
and in the future, as the
quality of service improves,
as AI is fronting some of these calls,
we see a renaissance of
interactions with brands,
and we think that's a good thing.
But as level 1 and level 200 work,
the easy stuff gets automated,
we see the average handle
time starting to increase
because it's the complex pieces
of work that hits humans.
So again, our perspective
on the contact center
and the value that it's driving
needs to fundamentally shift
as we drive up the voice volume.
And that's necessarily a good thing
because we think that
speaking to your customers,
solving their issues,
resolving their issues,
and also giving our agents
time to upsell, to cross-sell,
to actually properly service customers
delivers fundamental
value to the business.
Going back to the quality conversation,
there was a clear view from our customers
and those we surveyed
that the satisfaction
ultimately will be higher
from AI-only interactions.
What we heard from the leaders
was ultimately customers
won't care whether they're
speaking to an AI or a human
so long as their issues are resolved.
And so I would say as long
as the quality is there,
we also agree that the
satisfaction will be higher,
and we're doing a lot
of work around voice AI,
executing procedures, self-serve,
making the interactions
feel really natural
to make sure we get to this outcome.
I think that one of the biggest
shifts in the contact center
is the definition of the
roles fundamentally shifts.
So I shared level 100 and
200 we believe goes away
and is replaced by automation.
level 200 and level 300
we believe become what we call VIP agents.
And then the question comes,
what happens with the workforce planners,
with the folks who design the IVRs,
what happens with the quality managers?
What happens with the schedulers
and the outbound agents?
And the list goes on.
What happens with all of these folks?
We think sort of a new role
in the contact center is born
and this is what customers told us
of something that we're coining
the AI service architect.
These are the folks that are
deeply thinking about prompts,
that are thinking about correcting AI,
that they're thinking about
kind of managing the cockpits
of human and digital workers
working together in symbiosis,
and essentially, like, a
higher order of thinking
as the orchestrator in the contact center.
What's interesting in the Zendesk platform
is because we've got so much case data
and we've got such a
legacy of understanding
what customers call in and message about,
we're actually able to use that now
to interrogate the knowledge
base of the customer,
having 40 or 50,000 customers
using knowledge bases on Zendesk,
to look at gaps in their knowledge base
and automatically generate
new knowledge articles
based on the case history.
And then those new articles
are reviewed by humans
or these AI service architects
and then get fed into the AI
to then drive more self-service,
and that resolution loop
continues going round and round.
So we think this title,
watch LinkedIn over the next year or two,
we predict the AI service architect
is gonna be a role for the future
that's gonna be incredibly important.
But then how do we
measure all of this stuff?
Because if we've said average
handle time is broken,
the speed to answer is
going to be milliseconds,
and I think most people
that I polled yesterday
and in fact the thousand
customers we spoke to
all had varying degrees of
abuse and disgust at CSAT,
so what's left?
How do we figure out
whether our contact center
is operating as it should
and delighting our customers?
We think that feedback is gonna evolve
from being something
that happens after a call
or after an interaction
to an always-on discipline
where you're taking
signals from sentiment,
you're taking signals
from whether the outcome
was resolved for the customer,
you're listening to the
tonality of the voice,
the pace of speech, the emotion,
and essentially coming up with
new ways to track ultimately
to make sure we've resolved the issue
or we've driven repeat business
or upsell from that particular customer.
I come from the hospitality world,
that was my previous role
before being in the
contact center industry.
And it always amazed me
that the unit of measure
in the hotel was that you
would send a guest an email
a week or two after they checked out
and you would ask a question,
"Would you recommend this to a friend?"
Or, "How was your stay?"
The issue with that is it's
typically two weeks too late,
they've forgotten about the experience
or it's looking in the rear-view mirror.
The best measurements
happen in the moment.
And so we think now using AI,
we have a real opportunity
to understand the nuances,
the language, and the reasons for the call
and build up new dashboards
and insights to understand the customer.
We recently acquired a
company called HyperArc,
which is a digital insight,
almost like a data analyst in your pocket.
That's not the official brand term.
I'll probably get told off from
our PR team for saying that.
But essentially what that platform does,
it ingests all of the data
from all of the products across Zendesk
and allows you in natural
language to interrogate that data.
So it could be, "Why did my call volume
spike last Wednesday at 2:00 PM?"
And you can actually
drill all the way down
to the ticket in Zendesk
or get the higher-order
thinking and insight.
And it's got a concept of memories.
So every time you
interrogate the platform,
it uses a memory from the questions
that you asked at proceeding,
just like a human would.
And so over time, this platform, HyperArc,
gets smarter and smarter
and we sort of view that as
the future of navigation,
the future of really understanding deeply
the contact center.
But I started this talk
saying that the customers we speak to
and the customers we interviewed
feel like they're in,
well, feel like they're on
a plane, driving the plane,
changing the tires, and kind
of refueling all in one go
because there's so much
change in their world.
They sort of don't know
even where to start.
And what we've seen
and what we've understood
from our customers,
the ones that are most successful
take really discrete use
cases or micro moments
and reimagine them for an AI-first world,
implement them, A/B test,
have a look at the outcome,
and then they continue to roll those out.
And so our most successful
customers start small
and continue to grow and test and learn
and treat every interaction
as a learning experience.
It's still remarkable
to me that, you know,
some of our contact center clients
might have a thousand agents,
50 of whom will give out
incorrect information
all day long, every day.
And that's just viewed as par for course
in the contact center.
But as soon as a digital agent
gives one incorrect answer,
it's sort of code red issue.
And I think we're
starting to get over that,
but I think until we've
got a spirit of innovation
and, you know, a a want to try and test
within the contact center with AI,
I don't think we're gonna progress
as fast as other
disciplines of technology.
So I've given you a little
bit of a high overview
of what we see coming in the market.
I think the question that
Jay asked me backstage
from his college days,
well, the gremlins of the slides,
his college days is,
"Why is Zendesk talking
about contact center?"
So we announced the general availability
of Zendesk Contact Center,
which is a fully native, scalable,
resilient voice platform
that we believe can go toe to toe
with the best in the market
that is fully embedded
and native within Zendesk,
so that you can actually have
all of your communication
in one place
and orchestrate your AI,
your journeys, your quality management,
all in one place across all channels.
Our voice channel is in
partnership with Amazon Connect.
I don't know how the
slides keep changing it,
it must be very tired
as well on a Wednesday.
But AI and some of the voice capabilities
are in partnership with Amazon Connect.
We were very fortunate to be announced
as the global CX partner of the year
earlier in the week.
So Zendesk obviously
being the case management,
the quality, a single
platform without middleware,
and AWS providing us
world-class telephony,
resilience, AI routing,
and rich data and context
for our contact center platform.
And essentially, we
sort of center and focus
on four key value props for our customers.
AI that's built in.
It's interesting, some of
the contact center platforms
that are viewed as quite
modern, the SaaS platforms,
already coming on 10, 15 years of age,
the Zendesk Contact Center
platform being a year old
was sort of born in an AI era
and born from an AI-first architecture.
So we're not sort of
bolting on third-party bots
or third-party AI because
it's built into the platform.
We provide support for
the entire platform,
and as I said from the
resolution learning loop,
because your calls, because your tickets,
because your cases are in one platform,
we can learn from those, train the AI
and obviously you get a really nice loop,
a resolution learning
that that closes the loop
with the AI to make the human agents
more efficient and superhuman,
and makes the AI smarter and
smarter throughout the process.
Ultimately, what we see is a customer
should be able to contact
you on their own terms,
on their channel of choice.
So they might start on digital messaging,
they might get cut off
going into the car park,
that might trigger an outbound call
from Zendesk to the customer.
And if you can't get through, you know,
the AI then might leave a
message on the voicemail
and continue in an in-app experience.
Ultimately, a really
seamless, frictional journey
orchestrated with one set of AI,
automated in one platform,
which is Zendesk.
We already have customers
where we're seeing significant value.
This was for a fast food chain
where the after-call work went
down by about five minutes
and the average handle
time was down by about 50%.
And so that's happening
because we've got AI concierge up front.
When the calls actually
land with human agents,
we're supporting them with copilots.
A lot of the after call work is automated
from intelligent triage,
from sentiment, and from
the routing and follow up.
So we're driving tangible results,
and we wanna focus on those resolutions
and the outcomes for customers
and focus on driving those
rather than sort of dwelling
on some of the metrics
that no longer matter
within the contact center.
So thank you very much for
your time and your attention.
The Zendesk booth and some of
my very intelligent colleagues
are down there at the end.
It's in green.
We can actually buy Zendesk Contact Center
on AWS Marketplace,
and obviously that draws down
against your PPA and your EDP,
and it's all hosted on AWS as well.
So we're really excited
to have won the award.
We've been really excited by the momentum
and the partnership with Amazon Connect.
Delighted to have a number of our partners
globally in the audience.
Thank you very much for your
time, and enjoy re:Invent.
Hopefully we survive two more days.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)